thanks for coming out everybody thanks
to welcome and yeah [ __ ] there's
[ __ ] tape all over it man wieszczyk
Lovitz was working this like a Bob Dylan
[ __ ] harmonica and they're probably
expect you to fellate it at some point
so maybe they wanted to cover it that's
annoying it's like working with an uncut
[ __ ] man you're trying to roll that [ __ ]
back where's the [ __ ] head you're
Scott man I never saw it here's cut what
strain are you smoking tonight tonight
as OG Kush OG Kush but that being said
[ __ ] are you cut or what yes I'm
circumcised did you ever know anybody
with a roll back model no in what sense
well not intimately well ago but you
know no likey I'm [ __ ] into the
showers at school or [ __ ] your buddy
who's always like look at my own cut
[ __ ] no I don't think really I think it
became sort of standard operational
procedure for a certain generation of
young men it automatically happened at
the hospital yeah I think right around
the time of our generation yes exactly
so I don't remember any guys who were
all not sure all as they say this is
gonna sound so [ __ ] weird cuz people
will be like why do you know this but my
old man was uncut man my whole life and
I know this because my mom and my dad
yeah who you well you didn't meet my dad
but you met my met your mom did you see
pictures my dad and they look like
[ __ ] Middle America and she said
there's nothing remotely sexy about them
yeah my entire life until the day I
moved out of that house at age like
[ __ ] 22 23 both of them slept naked
all the [ __ ] time all the time so no
it did not
none of it warranted whistling oh holy
[ __ ] trust me I saw my parents naked so
many [ __ ] times dude who was crazy
and I just became [ __ ] David Gore for
me because they just trout trout
crouched around naked in the [ __ ]
house and then I have to remind him like
I'm bringing friends over they'll go
[ __ ] and they put on [ __ ] clothes and
stuff worse event of that yeah right
yeah we're making clerks we're in
post-production on clerks yeah and we're
staying at my house it's me and Scott
Mosier everyone else is gone and whatnot
we're cut in the picture and Scott was
still staying with me and we'd had this
big nor'easter flood so it took out our
house we were sleeping on just wooden
floors in the house we had to strip
everything down not unlike the hurricane
sandy [ __ ] that happened recently so
there we are like sleeping in my er in
my room no beds no furniture just put
like a mattress down I'm at one end of
the room he's at the other end of the
room and [ __ ] so Scott told me one
morning like we're sitting there eating
breakfast before we head out to quick
stops if we'd go to quick stop I'd work
at the convenience store Scott would
work at the video store cutting on the
movie for a while and then we'd switch
places and [ __ ] like that so we're at my
house eating breakfast he looks kind of
weird I was like what's the matter he's
like nothing so you know we didn't have
a relationship we were I'd only known
him for about a year at that point so
couldn't be like what's the problem man
yeah so I just figured it would come out
and [ __ ] we're driving too [ __ ] quick
stop's only like three miles from my
house and he's still kind of [ __ ]
weird and I was like oh you're right
what's going on he's like uh he's gone
now to tell you this man but I might as
well just [ __ ] put it out there he's
gone
I was sleeping this morning and you know
he's he's like I'm right here he sleeps
by the door to my room yeah he's like
the door was open dude and I heard like
floor creak or whatever he's like I
opened my eyes and I swear I wasn't
trying to he's gone but your mother was
standing there naked like she was
leaving I guess she left the room went
to the kitchen or whatever and the cook
naked you know just grab a drink or
something like that or [ __ ] a towel
to sup up my old man who knows why she
went but for whatever reason man she
passed by and then when she passed back
it was the perfect like [ __ ] freeze
where he was lying there and he opened
his eyes and all of a sudden she was
crossing and she was
looking to make sure that he didn't open
his eyes but then he did open his eyes
so she Deardon headlights and she hid
and moja always describes he's like it's
like it's like the Bigfoot movie cuz she
was walking and then she [ __ ] turn
and get the bucket looking [ __ ] and so
he was like I'm I saw your mother naked
I was like yes oh my many times yeah but
that was a real [ __ ] huge bonding
thing for me anyway to bring me back to
the point my parents and they get all
the [ __ ] time so I saw my old man he
was uncut as the [ __ ] day is long you
never saw the head of his dick which is
probably a good thing I guess I
apologize really just for that past 10
minutes
[Music]